(music)
My name is Neil Daswani. I am currently
the Chief Information Security Officer
at LifeLock.
I uh started a company called
Dasient, post my time at Google.
Ah, Google Ventures invested in the company that I
co-founded. And we got acquired by
Twitter in ah 2012, and I was up at Twitter, ah,
up until, um, 2015 when I joined LifeLock as
their Chief Information Security Officer.
After I got my undergraduate degree from
Columbia, ah, I had taken my first job
at Bell Communications Research where we were
focusing on kind of the future of the Internet.
We were building internet advertising
servers, and we're competing with
companies like, Double Click and Net
Gravity, at the time. And, ah, this was in the,
you know, late nineties. There's just a lot of
excitement around what was going on with
the commercialization of the internet
here in Silicon Valley. I, ah, at the same time
I, I, didn't have a graduate degree and to
apply to a number of graduate programs.
I, um ah, was lucky enough to get into the program
here at, ah, Stanford and I started working
on my PhD in Computer Science, ah,
in 1997 and that's what brought me to
Stanford.
(music)